en direct avec dominique pradalié
secrétaire générale du syndicat national
des journalistes
bonsoir dominique pradalié merci d'avoir
répondu favorablement à notre invitation
alors la france qui se fait happer doigt
sur les doigts par l'union européenne au
sujet de la loi sécurité globale votre
réaction
écoutez si la moindre des choses si le
président mâcon qui va présider l'union
européenne doit partir du 1er janvier
continuent à donner le mauvais exemple
au monde entier par ce type de loi je ne
crois pas qu'il en ressortira avec
beaucoup de de lauriers heureusement le
conseil d'état que nous avions saisi a
annulé une partie des dispositions les
plus liberticides
mais qui par un acharnement permanents
sont en train d'être réintroduite via la
loi séparatisme via la loi relative à la
responsabilité pénale et la sécurité
intérieure etc
il ya un acharnement de cette majorité à
vouloir restreindre abroger toute
liberté au lieu de protéger ses citoyens
dont les journalistes comme on le voit
pegasus effectivement l'interlocuteur
précédent le disait ça va crier ya un
peu puis c'est tout on oubliera on
oubliera on oubliera pourquoi pas ce
qu'on peut faire la même chose en pire
la loi séparatistes dans son article 19
et pire que l'article 24 que nous
dénoncions et qui a été abolie de la loi
sur la sécurité globale parce que il
interdit toute information susceptible
de donc il est encore pire la loi
séparatisme et en cours d'adoption par
le parlement français
maintenant on ne comprend pas comment un
gouvernement et un parlement ne
viendrait pas essayer de protéger ses
citoyens grâce à des systèmes haut lieu
d'enfreindre la loi européenne où la vue
sur l'air gp des hauts-lieux
d'enfreindre
la jurisprudence de la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme au lieu
d'enfreindre la constitution française
elle même qui dit que la police est
utile mais qu'elle ne doit pas servir
aux intérêts de la police alors
justement le conseil constitutionnel
avait donné raison à la contestation
populaire et vous avez donné raison à ce
que ça prouve finalement qu'il
déconnexion de la part du gouvernement
concernant les libertés fondamentales
effectivement on a l'impression qu'ils
sont hors sol et parmi les les critiques
les plus virulentes que j'entends qui me
sera portée seront ils ne tiennent que
par la police ou c'est ce qu'on croirait
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on me dit de
l'extérieur de notre pays où la france a
une image absolument désastreuse
désastreuse c'est plus du tout la patrie
des droits de l'homme actuellement c'est
la patrie qui a eu un texte des droits
de l'homme mais aucune action en justice
n'a abouti contre les violences
policières
je vous rappelle que plus de 200
journalistes en ont été les victimes
empêchés de travailler et nous ne voyons
absolument aucune
aucun frein à l'impunité qu'on peut
avoir certains escadron certains
certaine hiérarchie policière ou
gendarmesque qui se sont abattues sur
des citoyens paisibles
nous avons un commissaire mis en examen
au bout de deux ans voilà pour le moment
le rapport évoque notamment justement
l'interdiction de filmer les forces de
l'ordre qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
une fois de plus une atteinte à la
liberté de la presse à écouter sans
images l'événement est moindre voire
inexistant et c'est bien pour ça que ce
gouvernement fait tout pour empêcher
qu'il y ait des témoignages que ce soit
visuel photographiques ou même par un
journaliste présent on fait tout pour
éviter d'être qu'il y ait des témoins de
tous ces dysfonctionnements violence
barbarie parfois donc je pense que ce
gouvernement va continuer à s'obstiner
je vois les derniers projets de loi qui
sont sur la table introduisent une
surveillance massive massive sans
contrôle de tous les citoyens
donc je crains que le 1er janvier le le
président de l'union européenne et
beaucoup pas se faire reprocher merci
beaucoup et dominique pradalié d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général du syndicat
national des journalistes
merci